-Lately -- I don't need to
tell you that lately the new
has been abuzz about
the whistleblowers who hav
come forward with
inside information about
President Trump.
And here tonight is the original
anonymous whistleblower
bravely addressing the publi
for the first time.
Please give a warm welcome
to Mildred Mildew, everybody
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi!
Hey! Hi!
Oh, wow! Wow. Hi, Seth.
-So, wait, now. You --
You are the whistleblower?
-Absolutely.
-Okay.
'Cause I only want to have you
on the show if you are.
-I'm definitely
worth having on TV.
-All right. Well, tell us
everything you know.
-Okay.
Well, I blew the whistle
because Megan,
who's in charge of crownin
the community garden's
monthly flower king,
told me that my roses
were the most beautiful.
But the next day, her
e-mail blast to the whole club
said that Arthur's
were the best!
Which makes no sense, because --
-Mildred?
-Seth?
[ Laughter ]
-I brought you here
to talk about Trump.
-Oh!
His rose garden is great,
but I heard he doesn't
even grow them himself.
Just like Arthur.
That little rascal
actually hired outside hel
to tend to his flowers.
-So you don't know anythin
about President Trump
and his phone call with Ukraine?
-Why would I know?
-Well, you said you were
the whistleblower.
-I am. I'm the whistleblower
for the Royal Oaks
community garden scandal.
-Well, then, you know,
respectfully,
I'd like to wrap this up.
I only want to talk with you
if you have dirt for me.
-Oh, that's exactly
what my cousin
who works at the White House
told me Trump said
on the Ukraine call.
Speaking of sneaky phone calls
when Megan dated Arthur --
-Wait, wait, wait. Wait.
What did you say?!
-My cousin
works for President Trump
and listens to all his phone -
-No, no, no, no, no.
Did you say Megan?
As in the person
who decided the flower king?
-Yes.
-Megan used to date Arthur
Who she named the winner?
-For two whole years.
-That is messed up!
-I know!
-I mean, that is corrupt
to its core!
-I've been saying!
-I can't believe no one else
said anything.
What can we do about it?
Should we start a petition
What about a protest?
-Yes.
I made a shirt!
"Suck a tulip, Megan."
-This is big.